familiares de manifestantes muertos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
estatales realizan ceremonias fúnebres
el sur de Perú es el actual epicentro de
la violencia por las protestas contra la
presidenta Dina boluarte quien asumió El
Ejecutivo en reemplazo de Pedro Castillo
destituido por el congreso y detenido
por delitos de Conspiración y rebelión
aquí en la Plaza de la ciudad de juliaca
esta mujer exige justicia por la muerte
de su familiar por ese reclamo nos están
matando pueblo de juliaca estamos
muriendo queremos todo justicia queremos
estamos pidiendo renuncia
en especial cierre del Congreso a 41
kilómetros de juliaca en puno la
situación también es crítica el 9 de
enero será recordado como el día más
mortífero en un mes de protestas la
defensoría del pueblo de Perú reveló que
sólo ese día murieron al menos 17
civiles en enfrentamientos con la
policía lo que hizo reaccionar al
gobierno central que ordenó el toque de
por tres días en puno representantes de
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos llegaron al país para investigar
las protestas y la respuesta del estado
en la visita de observación el
vicepresidente de la cidh estuardo ralón
y el comisionado Joel Hernández se
reúnen con la presidenta de la República
Dina boluarte y altas autoridades para
recibir información del contexto actual
en Perú la atención sigue en todo el
país en el turístico cusco donde se
encuentra Machu Picchu se registraron
nuevos choques entre manifestantes y la
policía Mientras que persiste el llamado
a paro nacional indefinido y el bloqueo
de importantes carreteras como la
Panamericana Sur